>> HELLO.
I'M JESSY WATT AND JUAN WILLIAMS
AND IT'S 5:00 IN NEW YORK CITY
AND THIS IS "THE FIVE."
>> I WAS HAPPY TO SEE ON THE
FRONT PAGE OF THE NEW YORK TIMES
FOR THE FIRST TIME THEY WERE
TALKING ABOUT SPYING AND SPYING
ON MY CAMPAIGN.
IT'S A STORY BIGGER THAN
WATERGATE.
>>.
OF
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP CALLS THE
RECORD BIGGER THAN WATERGATE AS
THE MANY CONTINUE TO EAT CROW
AND THE NEW YORK TIMES TALKING
ABOUT HOW FAR IT WENT DURING THE
SUMMER THE FBI SENT A FEMALE
UNDERCOVER INVESTIGATOR TO MEET
GEORGE POPODOPOLIS WAS MET A
JAR.
>> SHE WAS TRYING TO DO TWO
THINGS, FIRST, EXTRACT
INFORMATION ABOUT MY
PROFESSIONAL CONNECTIONS IN THE
MIDDLE EAST AND TWO TO SEE IF I
HAD ANY INFORMATION SHE COULD
POTENTIALLY EXTRACT FROM ME
ABOUT TRUMP AND RUSSIA WHICH IS
NONSENSE.
WHEN THE NEW YORK TIMES
SUGGESTED IN THEIR REPORTING
TODAY THE BRITISH WERE TOLD OF
THE OPERATION, I BELIEVE THE
BRITISH WERE ACTIVELY SPYING ON
ME AS WELL.
>> AND PROCESS THINKS HE KNOWS
WHAT HAPPENED.
>> I THINK WHAT HAPPENED BETWEEN
COMEY AND McCABE AND IT'S
CORRUPT AND I THINK HE LED AN
EFFORT.
THE WORDS SPYING HAS BEEN USED.
HE PROBABLY WAS ONE OF THE
PEOPLE LEADING THE EFFORT ON
SPYING.
>> AND THE MEDIA SUNS -- IS ONCE
AGAIN LOOKING FOOLISH LET'S TAKE
A TRIB DOWN MEMORY LANE WHEN
THEY TRASHED TRUMP FOR SPYING.
>> THE HAS A NEW FAVORITE WORD
AND EVERY TIME HE USES IT HE IS
LYING AND THAT'S THE WORD SPY.
>> THE PRESIDENT IS TWEETING IN
HIGH GEAR.
HE WANTS YOU TO BELIEVE HIS
CAMPAIGN WAS SPIED ON AND IT'S
ONE OF THE WORSE THINGS WE'VE
EVER SEEN FROM GOVERNMENT.
>> THE NOTION THAT SOMEHOW THE
FBI IMPLANTED, PLANTED SOMEONE
INSIDE THE CAMPAIGN TO SPY ON
THE CAMPAIGN IS JUST NOT TRUE.
>> ALL RIGHT, SO GREG, THE
MEDIA'S BEEN WRONG ABOUT THE
DOSSIER AND COLLUSION AND NOW
ABOUT SPYING.
I KNOW YOU WANT TO TALK ABOUT
THE HONEY TRAP.
>> I PROBABLY DON'T.
I WANT TO SAY THERE'S BEEN ONE
OASIS OF RIGHTNESS AND I BELIEVE
IT'S CALLED "THE FIVE."
WE'VE BEEN RIGHT THE ENTIRE
TIME.
BY THE WAY, I DIDN'T ENJOY HIM
SAYING BIGGER THAN WATERGATE
BECAUSE THAT WAS THROWING IT
BACK AT EVERYBODY SAYING
COLLUSION WAS BIGGER THAN
WATERGATE THAT'S LIKE SAYING
JUST SAY NO WHILE SMOKING A
JOINT.
IT'S LIKE MOCK EVERYBODY NOR
PAST TWO YEARS.
THE MEDIA HAS TO PLAY THIS DOWN
BECAUSE THEY'VE BEEN WRONG FOR
THREE YEARS AND CHASING THE
WRONG STORY.
THEY'RE LIKE THE REVERSE COLUMBO
SO THEY'LL SHOUT ABOUT McCANN
AND MUELLER BECAUSE THEY CAN'T
ADMIT FOR SO LONG THEY WERE
CHASING THE WRONG.
IT'S LIKE A GREAT EPISODE OF LAW
AND ORDER YOU KNOW LIKE THERE'S
ALWAYS A SURPRISE TWIST AND IT'S
ALWAYS THE ARCHITECT THAT KILLS
THE PERSON AND IN THIS CASE THE
RICH IS INNOCENT.
>> MAYBE COLUMBO IS THE BAD GUY.
THAT'S WHAT THE MEDIA IS.
THINK ABOUT THIS, UNBELIEVABLE.
THEY'VE SPIED ON A PRESIDENTIAL
CAMPAIGN.
THEY'VE TRIED TO COVER IT UP AND
JUAN HAS BEEN WRONG ABOUT THE
WHOLE THING.
>> THIS IS LIKE A CONVENTION YOU
GUYS ARE SO OFF.
I KNOW IT'S FRIDAY BUT IT'S NOT
FRIDAY NIGHT YET.
>> THE NEW YORK TIMES FAKE NEWS.
>> YOU'RE FAKE NEWS.
>> SABE -- SAYING THE FBI
IMPLANTED SOMEBODY.
>> YOU PAID A PAID INFORMANT
OVERSEAS.
>> THEY WERE DOING THEIR JOB.
THEIR JOB IS TO CHECK AND SEE IF
A FOREIGN NATION WAS INTERFERING
IN THE AMERICAN ELECTION.
THEY SEND SOMEONE OVER THERE
BECAUSE POPADOPOULS SAID THEY'RE
SELLING INFORMATION.
>> WHO TOLD HIM?
>> ANOTHER INFORMANT.
WHAT DOES FBI STAND FOR?
BUREAU OF INVESTIGATION.
THEY DIDN'T COME TO ANY
CONCLUSION.
THEY WERE PROTECTING AMERICA AND
YOU MAKE THIS JUST LIKE TRUMP
SAYING THEY'RE SPYING.
THERE'S NO EVIDENCE OF SPYING.
>> NOW IT'S PAID INFORMANTS
OVERSEAS.
>> I LOVE THAT CHANGING THE
DEFINITION OF WORDS WILL MAKE
PROBLEMS GO AWAY AND I REALLY
HOPE THERE ARE JOURNALISTS WHO
INVESTIGATE THIS THOROUGHLY SO
IT DOESN'T HAPPEN AGAIN.
HAVE YOU 25 DEMOCRATS WHO WANT
THE JOB.
THEY BETTER HOPE TO HOLY HELL
THEY DON'T STILL HAVE THIS
AMOUNT OF POWER THEY CAN DO THE
SAME THING BECAUSE THE PERSON
THEY HATE THE MOST IN THE WORLD,
THE PERSON WHO EVER EXISTED,
THAT PERSON IS THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES AND ARGUABLY
HAS THE EXACT SAME POWER WITHIN
HIS DOMAIN AND CONDO THE SAME
THING THE FBI AND CIA DID UNDER
THE OBAMA INVESTIGATION AND THEY
BETTER GET TO THE BOTTOM AND
MAKE STRUCTURAL CHANGES.
>> POWER'S BEEN ABUSED AND THIS
IS THE NEW YORK TIMES AND
INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY IN FRONT
OF AN I.G. REPORT THAT WILL BE
DAMNING.
>> THAT'S WHERE THE DEMOCRATS
AND MEDIA ARE ATTACKING ALL OF
THIS AND ESPECIALLY A.G. BARR
AND HIS TESTIMONY TO UNDERMINE
HIS TESTIMONY WHEN THE REPORT
PROVES THE GOVERNMENT
OVERSTEPPED ITS BOUNDS IT WILL
BE PROVEN AND EVERYONE IN THOSE
BUILDING LIKE COMEY ARE
TERRIFIED.
I WANT TO TELL YOU THE REASON
WHY IT'S SUCH A BIG DEAL, IT'S
NOT JUST THE SPYING.
IT'S THE SPYING IN CONJUNCTION
WITH THE FACT THERE WAS NO
DEFENSIVE BRIEFING OF THE
TRUMP-THEN CAMPAIGN.
THAT IS WHAT PROVES OUR
INTELLIGENCE AGENCIES WERE
DEPLOYED AND ARMED AGAINST
THEN-CANDIDATE TRUMP.
IF AT THE TIME THEY THOUGHT THE
CAMPAIGN HAD BEEN COMPROMISED
AND THERE WERE PEOPLE WITHIN THE
CAMPAIGN COMPROMISED THEY WOULD
HAVE BRIEFED THE PRESIDENT AND
BRIEFED THE THEN-CANDIDATE BUT
THEY DIDN'T THAT MEANS THEY
THOUGHT HE WAS OR WANTED HIM TO
BE THE RUSSIAN ASSET.
IT'S SPYING IN CONJUNCTION.
>> EMILY, THEY DIDN'T KNOW.
THEY'RE TRYING TO FIND OUT IF
RUSSIA, IN FACT, HAS PUT SOME
KIND OF ASSET INSIDE THE
CAMPAIGN.
THEY DON'T WANT TO BLOW
THEMSELVES UP.
THEY ARE MAKING A REQUEST.
WE HAVE EIGHT INTELLIGENCE
AGENCIES PLUS THE MUELLER REPORT
SAYING RUSSIA INTERFERED IN THE
CAMPAIGN AND JIM COMEY WHO NEVER
SAID A WORD ABOUT THE FACT THERE
WAS A COUNTERINTELLIGENCE
OPERATION AIMED AT DISCOVERING
WHETHER OR NOT RUSSIA WAS HIDDEN
INSIDE THE CAMPAIGN.
HE DID THAT TO HILLARY CLINTON.
HE ROW -- PROTECTED THIS
PRESIDENT.
>> HE PROTECTED DONALD TRUMP?
>> IF HE HAD WORD RUSSIA WAS
INVOLVED IT WOULD HAVE
DEVASTATED.
>> THEY CARE MORE ABOUT POLITICS
THAN NATIONAL SECURITY?
>> NO.
>> YOU'RE SAYING HE DIDN'T DO
THAT PUBLICLY BECAUSE HE DIDN'T
WANT TO INTERFERE WITH THE
POLITICS OF IT.
AS THE FBI DIRECTOR STAY OUT OF
THE POLITICS.
>> IT WOULD BE WISE AT THIS
POINT AFTER ALL THE TIME TO STEP
BACK AND LOOK AT WHAT'S
HAPPENING THIS WEEK.
YOU'RE SEEING A LOT OF
NARRATIVES COLLAPSING THE
MUELLER REPORT'S OUT IT'S NOT
WHAT YOU WANTED.
I UNDERSTAND.
MEANWHILE TRUMP'S DOING PRETTY
GOOD AND YOU HATE TRUMP'S GOOD
THAT'S ANOTHER NARRATIVE THAT'S
COLLAPSING.
I THINK THE DEMOCRATS SHOULD
TAKE A TIME-OUT AND VACATION
BECAUSE IT'S NOT GOING WELL FOR
YOU.
YOU HAVE THE GREATEST ECONOMY
AND WATCHING UNEMPLOYMENT
NUMBERS FOR HISPANICS AND WOMEN
AND IT'S AN INCREDIBLE TIME TO
BE ALIVE AND YOU'RE SO MAD LIFE
IS GOOD, SOMETHING'S WRONG WITH
YOU.
>> THAT'S WHY THE PRESIDENT IS
TALKING THE FRUIT -- OH, WE
DIDN'T MENTION IT.
>> YOU WONDER WHY GOOD NEWS
MAKES YOU SAD.
GOOD NEWS MAKES ME HAPPY.
>> YOU DON'T SEE ANYTHING.
>> EYES ARE WIDE OPEN.
>> LIKE DEMOCRATS AND SOCIALIST
WHEN IT COMES TO THE ECONOMY
CLOSING THEIR EYES TO THE
NUMBERS AND HOW TO COMPOUND IT
AND MAKE IT BETTER THAN IT IS?
TELL ME ONE PERSON RUNNING FOR
PRESIDENT ON THE DEMOCRAT SIDE
PROGRESSIVELY ONE OF A PROGRESS
STRIPE TALKING ABOUT TAKING THE
ECONOMIC DATA AND MAKING IT
BETTER.
>> THAT'S ELIZABETH WARREN IS
ALL SAYING AND BIDEN GAVE A